now this is the forklift you need you
need a license to operate this machine
that means the upstairs office workers
can't drive it quiz Mike should you
drive the forklift I can and I have no
no no no no no I said should you you
should not drive it you should not drive
the forklift you understand you're not
allowed to drive the forklift it's not
safe you don't have a license guys I'm
not the only one who's driven the
forklift pudge's driven the forklift man
I thought your name was PUD no it's
always been M
okay um her her yes her is qualified to
work a dangerous machine you are
not okay fine do you understand that yes
we do safety training every year or
after an accident we've never made it a
full year this particular time I was
reaching for a supply box on the top
shelf when one office worker who shall
remain nameless kicked the ladder off
from under me and yelled hey Daryl how's
it
hanging and I fell and busted my ankle
and I'm legitimately scared for my
workers these are very dangerous
machines down here and the upstairs
workers
Michael should not go anywhere near them
yes yes but it wouldn't be the worst
thing in the world it would be the worst
thing in the world it would very much so
it's a big red trash compact D
disrespect I got it I got it only on the
rarest of occasions would I go there is
no occasion for you to go near this
stuff okay hey you're going to you're
going to hurt yourself Mike stand clear
Mike get off of the lift please fine
fine I'm fine here go would you
look
no we'll get somebody to clean that up
we're the ones that got to clean that up
damn it Michael we have to have this
thing service cold front coming into the
warehouse uhoh better put on your ski
boots
wow happy New Year
Daryl hey
Daryl you ever done
this right breaker one night
copy that breaker those Duke boys are at
it again hey do not touch my radio we're
not kiding we're not doing
anything here we go four times a
[Music]
charm here in the next day sometimes you
do the you don't sometimes you do
out
there
hey crying
no allergies no did Daryl touch you
what hey hey
hey you idiot start over
sir I placed a bunch of golden tickets
into five separate box boxes and somehow
they all ended up a Blue Cross how does
this happen what the boxes near each
other irrelevant I put three pallets on
a truck to Blue Cross once a week they
use a lot of paper okay I'm going to ask
you something and I want you to be
honest what is a
pallet well let's just say whoever was
ahead won that was you it was us really
I didn't I didn't
know great I mean I guess you guys
working Saturday your face
no no no I'm I'm not coming in on
Saturday yeah this isn't
happening
um well guys you know I am the boss so
yeah so what what's that we we coming in
on Monday
right
Monday you guys believe me come
on dog you know you should know me
better than
that no oh do you think that would have
been good for morale no no no exactly no
I'm I'm embarrassed it was even that
close so now of course we're coming in
Saturday got to get in on this hey it's
cool man I work in the warehouse I'm
cool I'm Hipp and I'm J but I don't care
about nobody do you know who I am happy
h Halloween jerk still don't know who I
am I'll give you a
hint I go over other people's heads
Michael this is a bad idea what's a bad
idea dressing up as somebody I mean when
has that ever worked for you
never okay you know what fine I'm not
Daryl and thank God I'm not Daryl could
you for once just let us enjoy a party
instead of making it about all your
issues this is
ridiculous you think they disc people
for bringing in balloons hey I think
this guy playing Sweeney Todd is my
plumber no Daryl this guy's a world
class actor do in daylight is your
plumber no it's my plumber say on his
bio apparently the director discovered
I'm doing K it's his first play he
didn't even audition are you kidding me
sh if we don't listen to the Overture we
won't recognize musical things when they
come back later all right I'm
sorry
God
[Music]
my claims we're all a family you know
right we are we are a family okay so um
what's his name all the way in the back
yeah oh very funny what's his name
uh I'm thinking Roy Roy left years ago
what's his name I don't believe I have
had the pleasure Michael I gave you a
ride home last week and we spent an hour
in traffic what's his name Jefferson
nope his name is
[Music]
Michael managing
by walking around this is our warehouse
or as I like to call it the H house but
don't you call it that I've earned the
right fine don't worry about that and
here we have M rogers's neighborhood
come on over here hey this is Ryan he's
temping upstairs what's up and this the
farman M rajas it's not my real name no
it's Daryl Daryl is
mjas Daryl Rogers they Filman then reges
then re then Roger then MAA
Rogers let's get down to business why
don't you tell me why you think you
deserve a raise well it's simple Mike I
mean we merg these two branches right so
now we're shipping twice as many orders
as we used to and with Roy going we got
a smaller crew and I'm picking up all of
his slack so I think I should be
compensated fairly by getting a raise
those
are but but I can't hear you that was a
very good point I can't what Mike are
you you make very compelling
argument